gaza's largest hospital is under
siege Israeli tanks and troops entered
the alifa compound early on
Wednesday hundreds of patients fill its
corridors while thousands more
Palestinians are Sheltering within the
complex and when our troops open this
Israel has insisted alifa is being used
as a Hamas Command Center it released
video claiming it soldiers uncovered
items belonging to Hamas it couldn't be
independently verified Hamas is always
denied using the hospital as a base it
is a civilian Hospital there is no any
member of Hamas in shifa hospital there
is no any military activity in shifa
there is anything happened when they
enter the hospital and all what happened
it is around the hospital but inside the
hospital all of the people in the
hospital are civilians
Israeli soldiers were said to be
interrogating doctors and medical staff
no one was allowed to
leave it's a complete blockade on the
alifa medical complex no one can go
anywhere no one can move between
buildings of the
complex this doctor is trying his best
to rescue the young girl she's a victim
of the Israeli
bombardment ala's emergency director
says the situation is
desperate they are in every building of
the
hospital the every place everywhere the
Israeli occupation forces are there and
uh people are terrorized and and
horrified because of the current
situation the situation is bad women
Children Medical Teams are
suffering inter humanitarian law
protects hospitals but now they're at
the front line of this war pushing the
Health Care system to the brink of
collapse Mike leel Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer